the Trump administration is now
admitting that they've lost track of
about 20% of the parents of the toddlers
who have been separated from their
parents so kids of all ages have been
separated from their parents at the
border looking specifically at those
five years of age and younger the Trump
administration said during a conference
call with both reporters and a judge
that they are unsure about the
whereabouts of one in five sets of
parents of the toddler's separated and
it's not clear if and when they are
going to be reunited a US District Judge
Dana
Sabra was on this call Friday this is
related to the deadline the
administration was given a deadline of
tomorrow July 10th for reuniting these
separated toddlers with their parents
and originally the Trump administration
said they were gonna meet that deadline
they then backtracked now they're going
to miss the deadline and the new number
is that roughly half of those under five
will hopefully be reunited by tomorrow's
deadline and Alice Olsteen from Talking
Points Memo has been following the court
cases around this and she tweeted as
this was developing the Trump
administration just told a federal judge
that 19 parents of children under five
years old have already been deported
they are arguing that they shouldn't
have to reunite them with their kids the
ACLU is pushing back the kids under five
are in the u.s. at these internment
style detention centers the parents are
gone the parents are no longer in the
country what do you do next this is a
humanitarian crisis it's a moral crisis
it's a legal crisis in the sense that
are there going to be any repercussions
to anybody for not reuniting these kids
with their parents that's not being
discussed also not being discussed is
the financial aspect here it's not cheap
to keep these kids
after you've deported their parents why
would you do it even if you lack empathy
for the kids or the parents even if you
don't have a compassionate bone in your
body what about the cost of this why not
send the kids back with the parents and
it's the party supposedly a fiscal
responsibility it's the president who
campaigned as Trump did on being
fiscally responsible
what is fiscally responsible about this
and of course the truth is fiscal
responsibility is a propaganda line it's
never actually a priority it's something
you say and when we actually get down to
it and we think about going beyond now
just the the child migrant crisis the
blue states subsidized the red states
red states lack infrastructure they lack
education they lack access to health
care because their economies are by and
large not working and without the blue
states like California New York
Connecticut Massachusetts New Jersey
Illinois Minnesota actually is is one
that pays in much more than they get out
federally without those blue states
places like Mississippi and Alabama and
Virginia although Virginia's kind of
purple New Mexico West Virginia Alaska
Indiana a lot of these places would be
screwed full-stop like I don't have to
qualify it in any other way but you know
who does win hugely from these
detentions of the kids of the adults
whoever it's the private detention
companies it's the banks that own huge
interests in those private detention
companies it's a huge score for them and
part of this is immoral policy part of
this is incompetence they've literally
lost track of what's going on and they
are not only unable to get everyone
reunited at this point it's not even
clear it's legally possible because the
parents of some of the kids are gone pat
they're not even in the United States
you're not going to reunite them you're
simply not and I'm curious to see
ultimately what happens with the
deadline and are there any repercussions
the administration already saying well
half of them simply aren't going to be
reunited our goal now is 50% will there
be any consequence to the Trump
administration
if you think the answer might be yes let
me know how because I am NOT optimistic
about that send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show we'll take
a quick break and be back after this
huge news weekend that I want to tell
you about I'm really thrilled to tell
you that today's program is made
possible in part by better help calm
slash Pakman as many of you know I have
been working very hard on this program
to reduce stigma around mental health to
reduce stigma around seeking help and I
have a family that is very involved in
mental health and if you've not already
heard about better help it is a
tremendous resource better help gives
you through your phone and computer
affordable private access to licensed
trained accredited experienced
psychologists counselors therapists and
clinical social workers who were
dedicated to helping you through
whatever is going on in your life you
just go to better help calm slash Pakman
fill out a questionnaire they will match
you with a counselor that will work best
for you
they are LGBT friendly you can even say
I want a counselor who's not religious
if that's important to you if your
initial match isn't a good vibe you can
switch to a different counselor and the
beauty is that not only do you get
unlimited counseling over videophone and
text from at home and on the go it is
way cheaper than in-person counseling
and after three months it becomes even
cheaper for you they also have financial
aid for people who need help paying but
you get the same professional licensed
therapy that you would by going to
someone's office and I believe that so
many people would benefit from therapy
whether you're dealing with an acute
situation in your life whether there are
bigger picture difficulties that you're
experiencing please consider checking
out better help calm slash Pakman it's
easy to sign up and get started we've
put a link in the description
if you're watching on YouTube once again
that is better help calm /pa que ma n